but there was one time that i act like i
thought he was sleeping so i quietly fight
in the bed did he giggle he rolled over
he smelled it and he actually yelled at me
and he was like that is so [ __ ]
unattractive what i've been with you
for a year and i've had to put up with this
for a year in the world same guy no yeah
hello and welcome back to
another episode of big moves
say you missed us say it
we don't know you missed us
today we have the beautiful the stunning the one
that looks like she's 18 forever and
ever and ever and ever nikki limo no
oh my gosh and then of course you guys
heard we have nikki and then there's me
gina hi hi gina hello today we are talking about
uh what married people miss about being single
and we have two ladies here who are happily i've
been married and divorced twice yeah she's been
married divorced twice and this is about to be in
her actual happily ever after after a very healthy
good relationship now and i'm so excited
for her yeah thank you yeah and nikki is
married to scumbag steve i love him he's the
best i love him that's my nickname for him
he's the best sweetheart steve he really is
and i'm holding it down for the uh non-married
single team the single team that's me so you know
you're doing it right thank you got a good balance
here yeah they both have experience in being
married anna we found this uh list on buzzfeed
of people telling us what they miss most about
being single and you know or not being married
and i figured we'd go through it oh i'm excited
i'm excited too because i'm really curious about
what the items are making some sense yeah it's my
two years yeah i can't wait to hear your thoughts
too and you've been through several yeah and you
have experiences from both that are right very
valuable to share i think i want to i want to get
that from you and i want to know like yeah yeah
what your expectations would be of if you were
married like am i normal for feeling this way
yeah okay and then um so i haven't read through
the article yet not because i wasn't unprepared
we are always prepared always and i just burped
into the mic that was just planned so i wanted
to read through it and for it to be like the first
time yeah very natural i love that that's the best
so let's start the first one is i miss the quiet
except for tv music or video games it was so quiet
in my house now with the wife and three little
girls it's a mad house sometimes when it's just me
and the dog i look over and i apologize to him i'm
so sorry scruffy i have been in loud houses before
can't say our house is like that cats
are pretty quiet right we don't have kids
right so i don't know if that's a a
married thing as so much as a parent thing
um jess you had a child that's true was it wow
yes i did and yeah oh my god that's true like
oh my god that's right i did i had to try it um
a long time ago i'm living like both worlds now
because lacie is an eight-year-old uh her one
of her very closest friends is also gay and so
it was her egg and they had a surrogate
and so we have magic baby quinn who yes
children are loud and very energetic and then
it's quiet so it is a parenting thing for sure
and then when i had corrine all of my attention
went to her but i worked a lot so i don't even
know i blacked out yeah i guess when i have kids
i could better relate to that i do enjoy quiet
i'm not and that's why i can't have a dog i think
because i always heard my neighbors dogs and i i
like cats they're quiet quiet right nibbler except
for this one he's kind of very vocal i love it
nibbler yells at me all the time yeah he
touched me he's very demanding he's the
dog cat he is but i don't mind him either
i think he's he could be a gateway to dogs
but were they quiet before is that my thing
because i'm pretty loud women well women women
in marriages oh like i lacie's like you talk a
lot like you're yeah yeah i wouldn't noise it
yeah i definitely am i talk to myself and i am
i don't realize it um but he's also tucked in
a room like a way right like i don't know like i
feel like when we [ __ ] when we had an apartment
and we both were working from home at the same
time because when we got together he actually
went to work and then there came a time when we
both worked from home and that was weird it felt
like i felt a little encroached on because i like
having a quiet house all the time and like doing
my whatever i do and like that way if i have to
cry or yell or scream no one's like judging me too
of your own space because i guess i am loud but i
like everything else to be quiet right um but um
yeah he uh he would clear his throat a lot and i
remember getting like annoyed annoyed at it yeah
and you're like why doesn't he realize he does
that and while he's reading he's just always like
just old man noises oh and you're
like is this a twitch i'm so confused
i'm not gonna complain to him because it's i don't
want him to feel bad about it yeah and then he's
all self-conscious but i just i'm like we need
offices we definitely need separate offices and
i think that's what it comes down to is like the
house is going to be loud with little ones and
where can you carve out time for yourself yeah
like also for mental health yeah you know and
you definitely need to to have alone time like eat
whether that's going to the gym or going on a walk
around the neighborhood you're locking yourself
in the closet and yeah snickers no judgment the
balance has to be there for sanity purposes
so how about you casey like you came into tiff
and isaac does it ever feel like it's
like when it's like he's just never quiet
it was a lot to handle and comprehend
he said he's like me he enjoys quiet
and sensory they moved in with him it
was just a lot to process at a time
i totally agree with that you appreciate
it yes now in the quiet it's kind of like
oh it's a good thing it's a good save
casey yeah you learn to appreciate it
that's a trained husband uh okay so the next one
says i miss when things were where i left them
hi excuse me who touched the bread who touched
my snickers i obviously have some trauma around
snickers yeah seriously like she has a horde
of snickers i think i can always get your free
birthday now i think absolutely sneakers yeah
are you okay no that's true because you maybe
put something down and then they picked it
up was it like a phone charger because this
has caused many of fights and marriages oh you
know what i mean stop touching my phone charger
that was like a big point of contention joe's
my marriage yeah i'm like can you not take my
charger again i'm kind of the opposite so i'm a
scatterbrained crazy bird like i i put my keys
down and i'm like where did they go i just had so
much action and steve always knows where they are
and i'm like it's so helpful to have someone that
knows where the [ __ ] i put things down i know
where everything is and vice versa like he'll be
like i can't find my glasses i'm like they're um
under the shelf on the bed like um under like
on the by the sock that you put there lift the
notebook there they will be there there they
are yeah that's me yeah lacy will misplace her
phone or her keys it's always the phone or
the keys yeah i always know where they are
yeah and i think that's such a good i think that's
the sign that's the one that's the sign that
that's the one if you're losing something and they
know where you're going to find it that's the one
that's the one well i lose things all the time
so i guess it wouldn't change very much for me
it's a single person but also earlier i was
thinking as a single person it is really nice
to just have my house completely silent when i
need it to be yeah yeah like i whenever we go out
or like i have work or have friends all the time
when i'm going out with them it's nice to come
home and it's just quiet and it's how you left it
yeah no one picked up anything and misplaced it
you know snickers um ever since steve got his own
like little man cave because i like everything
to be a certain way i get to be decorated a
certain way i like things to be in a certain
place and it's mostly for my own sanity because
i will create chaos wherever i go i'll make a
hurricane of objects wherever i go if things don't
have a system and so i created these systems so
that i can keep my house tidy because otherwise
it's going to be a disaster and so um when steve
didn't have his little man cave office the system
would constantly be getting [ __ ] with and i'm
like i can't my head is not it's not working and
nothing's working and then giving him his own
space he can mess up his space as much as you want
i never see it it doesn't affect the other systems
and i think systems are ideal and so we have a
very happy marriage i was just gonna say that
comes down to communication too because imagine if
you weren't communicative and he was messing with
your systems and you thought nothing's working
and then you projected that onto your relationship
where you're like nothing's working we aren't
working i think that's what happens a lot of the
times is you can't figure out what the problem
is other than that other than the variable that
there's new persons in your life right it's like
you can't really pinpoint what's driving you up
the wall so then you just start blaming them for
everything because you're like this working it's
just you it's you um i put my body wash here
you took a shower you moved it we're done yeah
we're done but then i think being aware of like
what is the thing the like exact thing that they
did break it down is throwing you off and then
you can yeah you work backwards from there and
if you're able to communicate with that with them
usually if they care about you and they love you
they're like oh okay yeah no we'll work around it
like we'll figure out a solution together and and
those are the building blocks of like a foundation
of a healthy relationship is just learning how to
make each other's lives easier and that's how you
know they're the one too that's true oh yeah the
one shitty guy i dated he had like a two sinks
and it was completely empty because he kept it
super nice and clean except for one side he had
a toothbrush and i just had to use that side
for the makeup because there's a double mirror
and he would yell and say why can't you just do
your makeup on the other side i'm like all you
have to do is just take your toothbrush and go
ahead and move it over because you just needed
the sink yeah and he's just a double-sided and
i'm like are you seriously starting a fight over
this and he goes oh yeah you're right i'm like
so that's good that's good advice that's
good nice communication look at us go us yeah
move your toothbrush we have some xp yeah
um peaceful sleep i miss not being beaten in my
sleep by my wife i bought a king-sized bed so you
can fight your dream ninjas on your side stay away
please and it's the snoring that keeps me awake
or wakes me up and another person says sleeping in
the middle of a bed like a starfish also eating in
bed and having five pills to myself is the best
part of being single and this is why a lot of
older people sleep in two separate beds yeah my
parents sleep in two separate bedrooms i always
thought it's because they don't get along anymore
but is this like a marriage it's a it's a snoring
yeah it's like uh my dad said she my mom snores
so loud and he used to like start kicking her
like not hard but like you know like yeah and and
that my mom would constantly be woken up by him
kicking her and then she was like getting upset
because she was like oh yeah yeah and so they were
getting into a lot of fights over the sleep over
the sleep so they they solved their problem by
switching rooms earplugs for me in a sound
machine and i sleep like a sardine anyway
this is i sleep like a geisha so this is how
she's on my sprinkles she's a vampire oh yeah
that's me sleeping on my side it's a genius why
are you an angel even in sleep that's not fair
i sleep like a drool machine and my face is
smushed into a pillow and it's just drool super
sexy still he's like you sleep like an angel it's
because he can't see my face because i'm turned
away from him but he just hears it he's like you
don't snore you just make this noise it's like oh
and i'm like that's really cute you sound like a
freaking thunder mountain and if i ever get woken
up in the middle of night i can't go back to sleep
but yeah guest rooms help oh okay yeah i just
sleep diagonal in my bed and then my cat sleeps
directly on my face that suffocates me at night
well i mean i can't breathe so we got panicking
or when i first brought him you like it i do
when i first brought him home he would wake me up
every morning by stepping directly in my throat
so that's always nice he's like
mommy i heard you ask for this
and he like doesn't see your boobs
and i see when he likes this you're a good boy
number four says money my money was my money to
do whatever i wanted with that's what they miss
about being single i think separate finances
can help a lot of marriages for sure sure if
there's one person that's like too controlling
over the finances i don't understand that
yeah um i can only speak from other marriages that
i've heard of uh in my family like other members
of my family like they uh i heard them talk about
how like so and so controls the finances and they
want to you know spend it on a vacation but
the their significant other wants to save for
retirement and they fight about it all the time
and i'm like oh i can't imagine that because if i
was contributing to the finances i feel like
i should have a say in the finances um again
systems it's like i think if you can establish
systems very early on in your relationship
the better the better yeah and and then you can
see if you're even compatible because there's
there's two components of a a good relation a
long lasting relationship in my opinion it's
uh compatibility is one and then uh what's the
chemistry is the other so sometimes people have
crazy chemistry crazy chemistry but they're not
compatible in any other sense like they fight over
the finances they fight over the the where things
should go they fight over everything else and
sometimes they're very compatible like on paper
they got everything worked out they're very smart
they just don't like to [ __ ] each other there's
like i can't imagine kissing him yeah it's like
being married to you like it's like and i feel
like there's when you listen to married couples
there's so there's two distinct ways to tell which
one it is like one will be like you know marriage
is like a business you know you have to operate
and you know the sex is going to die and blah
blah blah blah but you keep going because it just
works and that's really what the how the society
runs and then the other people are like this [
__ ] i [ __ ] hate him but i can't live without
him i [ __ ] gotta be with him i don't understand
like you look at this [ __ ] is everywhere blah
blah blah but i got a [ __ ] standard system
i am like okay you guys are chemistry you guys
are compatibility but you don't have both if
you can find a way to have both you will be
in a very good spot and that's also how you know
it's the one and that's how you know it's the one
but um so yeah early on in our relationship
steve owed thirteen thousand to the irs
and my dad's an accountant and he like helped
him out with that situation he didn't pay for it
a lot of people were like nikki's dad bailed
steve out no no no see paid for it he just
was able to work it down a bit um but yeah steve
didn't know that like when you're a 1099 employed
independent contractor that you have to set aside
your taxes yeah that um they don't get taken
out of your paycheck for you and so he was very
shocked at the tax bill at the end of the year and
a lot of people do encounter that problem and so
um after that initial going into the relationship
i was like okay i know how to manage finances you
go make money i'll help you manage the finances
i'll figure everything out anything he wants to
buy he anything over 500 we talk about it together
so big purchases we talk about together but
anything less than that he's free to buy whatever
he wants to buy i'm free to buy whatever i want
to buy we don't question each other and then
unless i'm like hey we gotta kind of be a little
bit more stringent towards the this week for until
the end of the month just because we're running
low on this budget right um he'll tighten up all
tighten up but other than that we don't really
you have a system in place yeah everything's
budgeted out we just everything's on autopay so
it doesn't really it's not really cumbersome right
that's good uh let me see number five says i miss
taking off and doing whatever the [ __ ] i want
whenever i want yeah yeah i think i i have i
always have a life outside of my partner yeah
and i think that's really important it's
really healthy to flex your independence
because otherwise yeah you will miss that and
that's not ever something you want to miss when
your relationship because then we go back to that
thing where it's like you're blaming them i can't
be myself or have fun with my friends because
you're here all the time all these different also
when you have kids too because you can't just see
that's different parenting a lot of these problems
i feel like are kid really like parent kid related
rather than marriage related because if you have
a healthy enough marriage where you're able to
communicate with your partner about your needs and
wants and they respect you for it i don't think
you'll have any of these problems with steve i
we both are very independent and i could not
imagine telling him not to do the things he
wants to do during the day and i can't imagine him
like when i was saying earlier when guys at the
poker table like your husband lets you just play
poker and like lets me like in what world would
i need permission like i just can't fathom that
that's a thing i would never be with someone that
needed me to ask permission to do something i want
to do and vice versa like if he wants to go out
unless it's like could i go to strip club every
night like obviously like we're going to have a
chat about that right that might be over the 500
limit yeah yeah true yeah it's out of our budget
cool it down but if it's like a it's a hobby
it's a skill it's something that you enjoy doing
like why the [ __ ] wouldn't you you should be
able to live just how you were when you're single
but as you are married also you're supported
right yeah like there's someone adding
some level of enhancement enhancement to your
life and gina said this earlier like it's between
talking about parenting and being single i really
do think it comes down to parenting and having to
navigate what does family time look like what does
couple time look like and what does alone time
look like and being okay with having to navigate
and manage time management yeah that's a lot yeah
time management and boundary management boundaries
yeah i think that's a lot to do with it but
yeah if you're out there right now and your
significant other is like controlling what how
you spend your free time i would have a i would
have a conversation about that because it's you
should nip it in the bud right now you should you
don't want to live forever with someone telling
you how to spend your free time rules on your own
time do you want to make it easy to refresh your
wardrobe with seasonal pieces that feel like you
well that's where stitch fix comes in it's easy
to get pieces to add to your wardrobe whether it's
date night dresses or cozy loungewear or even this
i got this jacket that's like a coat but then
it also is a hoodie like it can be dressed up
or it could be dressed down and i wear it with
pretty much everything jeans dresses everything
i love it stitch fix makes it so easy to update
your wardrobe with just a click of the button okay
here's what you're gonna do you're gonna go to the
website you're gonna fill out a little quiz it's
gonna show you like different pictures of things
you just click on the pictures that you like from
there a stylist will curate a specific style for
you and then they'll send you some pieces that
go along with that style and you pick the ones
you like send back the rest it's the easiest
way to get items that are just right for you from
brands that you know and trust like madewell and
sanctuary and you get looks that are just exactly
perfect for you so get started today by filling
out your freestyle quiz at stitchfix.com big mood
and take advantage of free shipping and returns
that's stitchfix.com bigmood to try stitch fix
stitchfix.com bigmood today's episode is sponsored
by honey the easy way to save when shopping on
your iphone or computer thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is the thing of the
past honey is the free shopping tool that scours
the internet for promo codes and applies the best
one it finds to your cart so here's how it works
uh when you're shopping on one of your favorite
sites at checkout the honey button appears and
all you have to do is click apply coupons wait a
few seconds as honey searches for coupons you can
find for that site and if it does find a working
coupon you'll watch the prices drop i've actually
been using honey since they started sponsoring us
years ago and it's been so useful because i don't
have to think about using the app it just pops
up by itself and it starts looking for all the
best coupons even like the most obscure coupons
and applies it and i've been saving money i
think one time i was shopping for clothes i don't
remember which site but it found a coupon for like
20 off new shoppers which it wasn't advertised
anywhere on the page but honey found it and i got
to save money if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by getting it
you'll be doing yourself a solid and supporting
this show get honey for free at joinhoney.com
big mood that's join honey.com big mood the next
one is uh i miss not having to justify myself to
another adult if i'm getting take out two days
in a row what no i would never you sound like
controlling poverty all right this is borderline
abusive like where if someone's like so possessive
of you that you're gonna get in trouble yeah if
you ever have to go in the car and order food
and eat it so yeah just how you don't want to
get in trouble yeah they're i don't know that
they're the person for you yes and there's
a difference like okay i don't know enough
details about this person's situations but there's
a difference if you've had a conversation like hey
your partner's like hey you don't have a job
and we're running low on finances we can't eat
out very often i gotta cook from home and then
you order takeout two days in a row then that's
different because it's a health thing you're like
yeah exactly you're putting something else in
jeopardy like another part of your life in general
in jeopardy and they love you and they want you to
be around or if it's like you're having heart
surgery tomorrow and they're like really you're
gonna just have a whopper yeah yeah yeah the
night before okay then okay conversation but if
that's not something if it's just like a regular
thing you both are adults and you're both making
money and you're both decide and you won't decide
you want to have takeout that should take out the
justification yeah uh the next one is i miss the
excitement of first dating someone you like i
vividly remember the last time i got butterflies
before i kissed someone for the first time
there is definitely something about the excitement
of meeting someone the anticipation when you
actually schedule time to spend together and then
the moments before the deep dive into something
physical don't get me wrong i'm a big sap so it's
her i'd like to experience it with again but yeah
it'd be so nice that we live those feelings again
this is why you have to continue to court your
partner absolutely one thousand percent we talk
about this all the time all the time tell you
um you definitely have to have a date night at
least once a week at least once a week i would say
once a week but if you can't if you can't do that
at least once a month you but you have to have
a date night a specific date night carved
out and that's not watching tv on the couch
that's like going out dressing up getting
nice like going on a date a proper date
looking good for each other looking good for
each other having good conversation having
a few drinks having whatever it makes you too
learning finding something new together i think
discovering new things together is our favorite
thing to do it's exciting it's like going to a
new place that you've never been to i love hearing
his opinion on it he loves hearing my opinion on
it we like are both processing new information
together keeping it spicy new experiences yeah
it makes me really sad when because it's very easy
for couples to once they get married they're like
well there's nothing left from here and so they
get really comfortable and routine it really wanes
the relationship and it's sad i remember there
was a rule that i learned about the 2-2-2 rule
which is you go on a date every two weeks go on
like a trip every two months and go on a like um
vacation out of country every two three years to
keep oh i like that yeah nice yeah we used to um
do a rule because we i mean i guess it
depends on what your love language is but
um we value experiences more than things so
we didn't get each other presents at all no
birthday anniversary valentine's no no presents
no christmas presents but once a year we'd go
on a lavish vacation like for a week you know get
away and just experience a new part of the world
together and we loved that but then the pandemic
happened yeah so we got a a robot bartender
investment and pretended we were on
vacation i like that that is a vacation yeah
we had a projector screen out there it was like
we were just watching survivor in the jacuzzi with
robot bartender drinks with your like mai tai like
it's like you know they're on an island and it's
like we're on an island uh the next one is i miss
being alone and not feeling guilty i have a wife
and daughter so when i do get a chance to be alone
for a couple hours it's amazing as hell but i feel
bad that i want to be alone i love them both to
death and would do anything for them but man i
miss my alone time i think that's so important
like independence my long-term relationships i
would tell them sometimes like hey i just need a
date to myself and literally that date to myself
is just me [ __ ] off on bed and watching anime
right you know eating snacks crumbs everywhere
like you just need that alone time and i think
it's hard for extroverts to understand sometimes
because introverts like you me and gina are both
more introverts than extroverts but you a lot
of people can't tell because we're like you know
we're out there when we're having fun we're having
fun you're introverted extroverts yeah we're like
we're socializing like we're here our energy's
here we're giving it but it's draining like
after that night it's like the battery went to
ten percent and we have to charge it back in by
being alone and that's the only way we charge and
so a lot of people that are extroverts don't
understand that like they're like okay you're
not going to talk to anyone like no like what are
you gonna do like alone like what do you even do
i just like to be alone with my thoughts social
batteries definitely is a thing and lacy's is
more introverted she's also extroverted and
people wouldn't know that about her but she is
more introverted and i would say she's more
introverted than me and she values her alone
time so on days where i'm here and i'm like doing
things where i'm gone for the day you know she can
sit on the couch and watch sports or go to the
beach alone and drive do whatever she wants
to recharge and re-center herself and it made me
realize that i also value alone time yeah and i
just never gave myself the opportunity see i think
introverts and extroverts they both need the same
things it's just that the difference is what they
get recharged by so steve he's an extrovert and we
both like alone time but he gets charged by being
around other people right he gets super charged
by like talking to people and being there and i
love being around people sure but i get charged
by being alone yeah and so that's those are just
the main differences it a lot of people think
that introvert means shy it doesn't like people
that are introverts it doesn't necessarily mean
they're like they're closed off and they're shy
and they don't know how to talk to people it just
means that that's how they charge is being alone
yeah you you and steve is how lacey and i operate
i think that's great it's a good balance it's a
great balance because then when he'll he'll just
like sometimes go out and i'm like great he gets
to go out and even if he's quiet at home i still
feel his energy totally and so when he leaves the
house and like goes to socialize and i get the
whole house alone it's like we both are getting
what we need to recharge it's great yeah there's
i remember like dating people who's like when i
tell them i need some you know just a day i'll
feel like what do you mean like you don't want to
hang out with me and they take it personally right
there's nothing to do with them yeah it's like
sucks i hate when that happens yeah exactly it's
like well you have a day off why don't you want
to spend it with me it's like dude let me chill
for a second i want to give you the best of me
exactly i think that's what they don't understand
so you have to get back to this is how i give you
a better version of me is by like letting myself
charge yeah and i actively offer it to them too
because like there are times when i'm like when
you're newly dating someone you want to see them
all the time but yeah i offer it to them too like
do you want to date to yourself like i don't have
to come over anything too like i try to be mindful
of that too because people need their alone time
it's great that you're mindful of that that's so
great uh the next one says i miss cleaning the
way that i want i have a thing about liking to
clean when no one else is around just because how
i do it takes time and has a weird system to it
i hate being observed while i clean i don't want
to hear that i miss a spot i don't want to hear
their method of cleaning i don't want to hear
anything i want to put my earphones in and just
enjoy cleaning oh i've never had two cleaners in a
relationship me either and i'm the cleaner i enjoy
cleaning i have ocd and i i think there's a method
i feel like if i was cleaning and someone said hey
you missed the spot i will punch them yeah totally
yeah and i don't support domestic violence yeah
but don't [ __ ] tell me i missed a spot right
now pointed out wind it up in my head i punch you
so yeah you're the cleaner i know your house is
always spotless and beautiful and you've been like
my inspiration for oh my god sometimes i go
over and i'm like that's how you organize that
oh oh so my house is a [ __ ] nightmare for
you right now no no it's when it's my personal
space like the way that i um take stress off of
myself and i recharge like blast music and i clean
how crazy does that sound it doesn't sound
crazy anymore because i never used to be a clean
a cleaner person but um once that system is in
place it's all about systems i swear like if you
can figure out a system that works for you it'll
organize your whole head and make you feel so good
um i love putting on music and cleaning but it
takes like three hours yeah and i need like to
go one room at a time one room at any time
i don't like people walking through the room
while i'm cleaning like you just stepped
into the pile that i was sweeping yeah
and he's not observing me and he's not
like commenting on it but if i'm cleaning
the kitchen and then he goes and makes a
meal i'm like great i was just cleaning it
i could have had an enjoyable day i figured out my
own system right so that's exactly i hired people
yeah it's my system i know i know my witnesses and
i know how to remedy them yes um i miss friends
don't get me wrong my wife has done nothing to
isolate me but when you marry your soul mate it's
easy to think that's all you'll ever need add a
long hour's job to the mix and before you know it
she's the only person you interact with away from
the desk then kids come along and you'd sacrifice
anything for your family especially free time but
the kids grow up and your wife craves time away
from you and the kids then one day you realize
you're alone that's what my parents are going
through they're like wow we uh we have to like
come home and there's no kids and um we don't know
what to talk about oh i mean they love each other
you know but they just they're like sometimes we
run out of things to talk about it's like how did
you sleep last night uh not good i mean either
food oh yeah me too oh uh so-and-so is coming over
later to check out the the leak on the sprinkler
oh okay exciting whoa i think that all comes
down to right date nights yeah date nights again
and also remaining independent of your partner
and having a life outside of them having hobbies
having hobbies figuring out like what you're
passionate about what lights you up outside
of your relationship and having the conversation
where you can you communicate early on that it's
really important that you both have independent
lives outside one another because then not only
are you guys both recharged but you also have
something to talk about when you get together
you're like oh my god you'll never believe
this like lately it's been a lot of like me
telling their crazy conversations at the poker
table and like there's a lot of characters and
i think it's hilarious and i think steve would
really enjoy them and so i tell them i tell
them all about it and we have a blast together
and then he tells me like about his bar friends
that he met and like what create they're always
like starting some crazy businesses and stuff
and we just like have a blast talking
to each other about what we did without
each other and that's the thing because you
spent time away when you're with someone 24 7
you don't need to ask about their day because you
know their day mm-hmm you were their day you were
you're the whole day you're the whole work um
i also think it's we're i'm in a kind of unique
situation where we have a lot of mutual friends
like steve and i got together and we were in
the same friendship group and so like jess knew
both of us independently before we got together
and i met jk independently of steve and then
he met them later and so it's like we are all
kind of you know in a mixed group like i don't
think there's a single friend that besides my high
school friends like i don't think that there's
friends that we have outside of of each other
and not on purpose it's just like we work together
we play together we everything's together but we
do have our hobbies where we meet other people
that's the best that's fun uh let's see the next
one says i miss not having to consider anyone
else when making a decision someone once said
being married is just asking another person what
they want to eat for dinner until one of you dies
i guess like i kind of enjoy that when i get
out of a relationship because now i'm just like
i can do whatever the [ __ ] i want and not
have to worry about well what are you doing
this weekend do you want to get you know like i'm
just like i just do whatever the [ __ ] i want now
yeah you can be selfish when you're single
right you're more selfish with your time
where you're not like i think something that
would happen in uh my marriage was that they
would be making something for themselves and
wouldn't ask if i wanted and then i'd be like oh
but i really wanted that's weird so yeah that's
weird because i know you cooked a lot for your
ex um too yeah so that wouldn't even be
a thought done to ask in your mind um
i think a lot of people want to be to flex
being selfish that's not the time yeah yeah
right yeah you know in our marriage um it's
i don't it's not that like where it's like
because i've heard that that meme before um it's
more just like are you hungry and usually our
hunger cycles are off and i was like oh i just
ate oh okay i'll make something or vice versa
and then if we are hungry at the same time it's
like oh what sounds good to you and it feels
like we're kind of like choosing an adventure
together like okay wanna try out this restaurant
now i don't know it might it sounds like it's too
filling okay i have something lighter okay so how
about how about this one it's like ooh that kind
of sounds good and then we just kind of get it
but yeah we make it fun i think like keep things
fun yeah keep things on adventure keep things
like new and interesting and routine's the enemy
it's not exciting yeah you have your system for
the boring things like cleaning like a system
to make it fulfilling but the like the partner
stuff like that needs to keep that fun keep it
fun and light it's different keep it going yeah
keep there being things to talk about things to
do together and if you want to be i i want to be
selfish with my time sometimes and you want to be
alone and you want to not you want to order food
for yourself and not have to worry about anybody
then schedule a night where they do something
with their friends or on their own and then you
have that time to be like what do i want yeah and
communicate like that communication huge thing as
communication is everything because if you have an
understanding loving partner it shouldn't be scary
to communicate your needs to them to say like
hey i kind of want a night alone is that
cool yeah and then they're like yeah okay
they should the answer should be [ __ ] yeah yeah
always it should be that um and everything if not
there should be like some crazy reason why
it's not and they're like i had a surprise
dinner planned yeah yeah or like oh my mom's
actually coming over is it okay if you just like
if you use entertainment for two hours yeah your
night tomorrow night or something i'm so sorry
yeah you have a compromise but yeah for the most
part it should feel more free than a lot of people
tell you it is um i just kind of feel like there's
this notion that marriage is this like ball and
chain like this traditional like yeah the old
school like the guy makes the money the woman's
the homemaker and you guys are just [ __ ] trapped
and like good good luck you know have kids and die
and like it just is so sad and it really
doesn't have to be that way in this modern era
where anyone is free to make the as much money
as they want uh like have kids or not have kids
get married or don't get married like you have
a lot of freedoms and so if you're gonna choose
something like marriage to commit yourself to then
you better be sure that you guys [ __ ] understand
each other and like it yeah like you like each
other and you like the system you have together
because it's now a legal thing that's very hard
to get out of so it shouldn't be something you
feel like you're settling on like definitely now
i'm trapped in this so i gotta figure it out and
make it work because it's too expensive to leave
and i have to ask them what they want to eat for
dinner yeah yeah until when he dies until one of
you dies and if this is you and you're having this
like just have conversations with each other
so that this isn't you so it's not a thing it
doesn't have to be hard it doesn't have to be
torture yeah to be together i always thought
that trope was so weird like you know people
have wedding cake toppers where it's like the
woman's dragging the boy the wife the bride is
dragging the the groom that was our wedding cake
oh my gosh it was because he played xbox all the
time and i had to plan the whole wedding and i
was like usually to play xbox and he's like i'll
help i was like i don't even know what to tell you
to help with because i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm doing and so he our our engagement photos were
um him playing video games and me trying to seduce
him and then that's right and then me playing
video games and him like pissed off and then our
wedding cake topper it was customized from etsy
and it was him playing grand theft auto which was
the game he was playing and drinking a coke zero
which was what he drank and me trying to drag him
away from it but it's that's more like dragging
him away from the xbox yeah old like the old
like balling chain yeah like um force him to get
maribel he's trying to run away like the woman's
always forcing me to get married like he said when
it's like true when people are like that's so true
that's so bad it should be a joke it should be a
big fat joke yeah yeah i've noticed that like
the worst um engagement posts on instagram from
you know it's a very problematic couple when this
the post starts with we've had our ups and downs
oh geez but here we are yeah we went
through the worst but we made it so yeah
we're happy for them like you know if you worked
it out and you resolved some really underlying
resentment and now you're like on a fresh page
that's great um but a lot of times they say that
when they're not coy yeah exactly they're still
working and they just want to plan a wedding
yeah yeah that's what people say they don't
want to get married they just want a wedding
but people just want that's what i want for
you i don't care if you get married just
[ __ ] have a wedding for me gina don't be selfish
but it doesn't even need to be selfish yeah
that doesn't even need to be a groom i'm just a
freaking fish in a fishbowl i don't care something
uh the next one says i miss traveling alone i
mean i can travel alone if i wanted to but it
would feel kind of mean to be like hey i want to
plan a really big cool trip and you're not invited
this tip went to a different sepurapora but that
was different because she had never been alone in
her life and so she kind of needed like a come to
jesus like where like she got to experience that
for once because uh she was a teen mom and she
was had a boyfriend or a husband and had had isaac
and then she was with isaac the entire adult life
her entire life and then she was with casey and
it was like she never experienced traveling
alone being alone doing anything alone she
felt almost like she couldn't maybe she couldn't
be alone and i think she needed to know okay i
can be alone now that i have that i'm happy i
have my family yeah i can appreciate it it helps
you appreciate your family more don't think too
much of one thing maybe does drive people insane
so too much aloneness makes people want to be
with someone too much of being with someone making
people want to be alone if you can just create
balance in your life um you'll you won't feel like
this is a problem from your partner right you know
like i think it's just a lot of things there's
people not voicing their needs right the balances
the systems in place and communication yeah i used
to go away for new year's um just on a loan trip
like just alone for three days like i'd plan a
vacation somewhere and be there alone and it was
great it's like a really reflective thing and
it's beautiful and you get to just like melt away
all the stress so it's yeah that's just ask for
it yeah uh the next one says i could go without
all the rank ass farts my husband farts sounds
like there's a man playing the trombone trapped
inside of him i hate them they're so [ __ ] loud
but at least they don't smell so i guess i
have to count my blessings they don't smell
i know that you and steve have a very strict no
bathroom sounds no farts no whatever each other
and you and tiff too right yeah gotten slack for
the sea like and i think it's i'm i've been won
over because um even though people comment like
that's you know you should be comfortable with
your partner blah blah blah look i was on your
team i totally get what you're saying i used
to say that i used to be like well it just means
you're comfortable around each other that's an old
meme how many couples do you know that are old and
married and they fart around each other a lot and
they hardly ever have sex yeah that's not sexy
and like you got to keep some level of mystery
magic and so steve came into my our relationship
like yo i have one rule we don't fart around each
other it was steve's idea yeah i had i was on
the other side i was on the like oh we've always
farted around each other like in relationships
once you get comfortable enough and i had to
ask him it was like because you're is it because
you're not comfortable around me or is it because
he's like no i got one piece of advice from a
married friend that still bangs his wife a lot and
it was that he they don't fart around each other
they don't poop around each other they don't pee
around each other they keep bathroom life private
and they still finding each other very sexually
attractive right and he's like i'll never forget
that and i will i really want to keep the magic
alive and i was like i've never tried it but in
every relationship the sexual desire has gone down
and we have farted around each other so maybe
there is some congruency to that i will try
your method and see if it works it works and
so far i am more attracted to him than ever
i don't know and he's you know he he's getting
older and getting way more attractive to me mm-hmm
so i've always not farted in front of my
significant others but i did date one guy
that had ibs and he was just he did not get it
but he didn't hide it all either like he didn't
try to at all so like about the intent yeah
we'll just be laying in bed and this rank ass
smell like dude did you fart he's like yeah i'm
like why didn't you warn me he goes oh yeah sorry
i was just like oh no like it gets annoying after
a while you know because then you're offended yeah
that stinks it's subconsciously makes you less
attracted to them yeah you know it's not even a i
don't even think it's a conscious thing because in
my head with my ex-boyfriends i was like i don't
know like i never associated it with the fart but
i think there is like a because they become more
brotherly yeah like who else does that in fact
my brother my brother does that in front of me so
and am i attracted to my brother no so you kind
of start subconsciously becoming my brother or
i'm like dude like it's like consideration you
know absolutely crack a window yeah i hate when
they think it's funny too exactly it's not
funny like we're not 12. but there was one
time that i act like i thought he was sleeping so
i quietly thought in the bed did he giggle was it
no he rolled over no he yeah he rolled over
he smelled it and he actually yelled at me
and he was like that is so [ __ ] unattractive
what i've been with you for a year and i've had
to put up with this for a year and the world was
the same guy no yeah and the windows were up the
recent one like it turned into a full-on argument
he's like that's [ __ ] disgusting that's so
weird yeah so weird yeah it was mean that's me
he's so mean and also just like hypocritical
how does he not see that that nurses what and
hello you thought he was sleeping you were trying
exactly right exactly it was wild if you do it
that's not that's yeah no yeah also you do those
in your sleep too so yeah yeah it just happens we
don't even know it it's wild what do you want to
eat tonight maybe you want a home-cooked favorite
but don't feel like going to the store or you want
something exciting and new but it would be great
to stay in tonight doordash connects you with
everything you want whenever and however you want
it get what you want to eat right now and right to
your door with doordash along with the restaurants
you love you can now get groceries and other
essential items delivered with doordash get drinks
snacks and other household items in under an hour
craving late night ice cream forget that one key
ingredient for dinner or maybe you just need to
stock up for the week with doordash get everything
in one app with over 300 000 partners you can
support your neighborhood's go-to's or choose from
your favorite national restaurants like popeyes
chipotle and cheesecake factory ordering is easy
and your items will be left safely outside your
door when you choose contactless delivery which is
awesome because then i don't have to make myself
like a decent human being whenever they drop it
off for a limited time our listeners can get 25
off and zero delivery fees on their first order
of 15 or more when you download the doordash app
and enter code big mood that's 25 off up to 10
value and zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code big mood don't forget the
code is big mood for 25 off your first order
with doordash subject to change terms to apply
bone apple tea do you feel overwhelmed when
shopping for skin care there's like so many items
out there so many trends so many ingredients don't
you just want someone trustworthy to be like hey
don't stress this is what you need and this is
why it'll work for your skin well that's why
custom rx treatment from row derm was created
it's personalized prescription skin care that's
designed with dermatologists to help you reach
your goals like getting clearer smoother healthier
skin may happen younger skin oh you don't think
that's possible it is have you heard of some of
this new technology okay well all you have to do
is complete a 10 minute online visit to share your
concerns like acne fine lines wrinkles dark spots
you name it all of the above and then also you're
gonna like tell them some of your medical history
and the visit's free and i love that you can do
it without even leaving your home because i don't
like changing out of pajamas if appropriate a us
licensed healthcare professional will prescribe
a custom rx treatment that makes sense for your
skin so it's made with a blend of dermatologist
selected ingredients tailored to your needs and
right now new members will receive a 30-day trial
of custom rx treatment plus rhodarm's hydrating
cleanser and protecting spf lotion for just five
dollars when you go to rowderm.com forward slash
big mood shipping is free and you'll get free
and unlimited follow-ups with your health care
provider to support you through your skin care
journey if you're prescribed get your first month
of custom rx treatment plus rhoderm's hydrating
cleanser and protecting spf lotion for five
dollars so go to rowdurm.com forward slash big
mood roadderm.com big mood uh the next one says i
miss controlling the remote at all times watching
anything without constant streaming commentary
oh yeah we don't really watch a lot of tv in my
house that's either i can't imagine if the tv was
actually i can my ex did that like he
needed to have background noise at all times
and i lived in a studio and
we lived together in a studio
and so there's no room to escape to too much noise
there's just a lot of noise at all times and i i
yeah it drove me nuts and like when he
was gone i was like the silence do you
i remember um like during dating like when you're
just getting to know people i was getting to know
this guy and every time we came over he was
like i really want to watch prison break so
we just watched prison break all the time
but i'm like i'm kind of bored of the show
um can we change it he's like and he's he threw
a fit what he's like no i don't like white like
i want to finish prison break blah blah like i'm
like all right peace out yeah you're not going to
work out yeah it's not going to yeah no if you
can't compromise it's just not going to work
i'm going to say it's all about compromise i love
rom-coms and i'm a rom-com girl and lacey loves uh
like mysteries and and thrillers i like those too
yeah and i don't can i just sit in the middle of
youtube so we compromise on those days i'm like i
won't look and you can tell me when it's over and
then i make her watch like hallmark with me yeah
oh yeah lifetime tv yeah oh i love a lifetime yeah
steve doesn't like cartoons like any animation and
i love animated that's adorable like pixar movies
and stuff and uh but i did make him watch wreck-it
ralph with me and he had to admit that he liked it
um and he did and he's like the writing was really
good i was like yeah see it's not just like some
cartoon kids movie okay and uh he really likes
action movies and i don't i don't like action
movies do you compromise yeah we both watch each
other's [ __ ] and um sometimes i admit like oh
that was actually a pretty good movie like they
had a plot line it's not just like bang bang bang
yeah everything explodes for no reason
michael bay movies i ate a cake it exploded
like he loves die hard and i'm like he made
me watch and i was like oh he's such a dude
also too if you compromise and you give
it a chance you might just like it you
might like it yeah that's what i don't get when
people get angry or mad or put up such a fight
it's like what are you scared of you might
like it yeah come on please the answer is
something yeah why something you're so stubborn
for no reason yeah uh and the last one here says
i miss not having to share my leftovers when i was
single i can treat myself to chinese food and the
leftovers were mine now i have to be considerate
and share it's terrible what again boundaries yeah
my leftovers are yours i don't like people having
my leftovers yeah i don't like leftovers so i'll
give you my leftovers oh i love it really yeah for
someone who eats like a starving raccoon i know
he just he i'm like are you a snob like why don't
he's like i just don't i just don't want to eat
it's leftover food it's not it's not fresh food i
don't like to eat it i'm like then why'd you bring
it home because he'll still bring it home and like
why did you bring it home and we used to i used
to eat his leftovers but now i'm a pescetarian
and he's a meat eater still and i can't eat his
leftovers so just it's a waste i'm like i don't
know why you order so much food then this man
cooks his chicken until it's ash yeah i think he
likes the taste of an ashtray garbage can a fresh
one and and so some some chef prepared food is not
not good no not up his alley i never finished my
food i always i'm a grazer throughout the day
so i end up taking the the food home and then
it's perfect because lacie loves leftovers and
so she'll eat them but if i bring something home
yeah that i want like chocolate cake like you said
nikki it's it's boundaries and it's like don't you
dare touch my [ __ ] yeah she's a dessert she's
a dessert monster yeah like every time she comes
over she's like i'll bring dessert i have
i've got no she's gonna she's gonna bring it
there was a phase we went through where she would
always come over and we'd go to the grocery store
and get cinnamon rolls and then bake cinnamon
rolls and it was so we'd watch movies and like
eat cinnamon rolls it was delicious and so good
there weren't leftovers then no one of my biggest
pet peeves when i was in a relationship was i
always share my food you know like if i'm eating
something i'm always going to share it and they
take the most giant [ __ ] bite oh the biggest
of the best bites yeah or like do you want some of
my drink and then they finish it and i'm like what
the [ __ ] and this is why we're sorry that's
not cute yeah what the [ __ ] man the only time
that steve and i have had and it wasn't even real
arguments is just like yo dude like stop what the
hell um was when like we would get an appetizer
like that we'd share together and let's say
there's like four cauliflower or let's say there's
like four of the thing that comes in like four egg
rolls he eats three of them and then i get the
one and i'm like i thought this was a partnership
i wanted that extra egg no it's not fair
is when they only put five egg rolls
oh yeah and there's two of you and you're like
can you just make it even because now we have
to figure out who's gonna be he's like and i
still ate the one or like i um i ordered egg
rolls that's why egg girls are popping up because
i ordered egg rolls as like i like to get like a
side if because i don't know if the main dish
is going to be big enough like because sometimes
in a new restaurant you just don't know so i'm
like okay i'm going to get eagles on the side
and the main dish was big enough so i didn't eat
the eggs yet but i was like i'm gonna have those
tomorrow it's gonna be sick and i go to put them
in the fridge and it's an empty container and
i'm like where the [ __ ] did those ankles go
and he's like oh i hate them i'm like did you
order across he's like i thought they were cape
for free oh my god boundaries steve boundaries
they'll come for free who gives eggs for
free what restaurant does that you wanted
though i don't know i thought it came with
my meal you thought it came with your shoes
yeah who keeps on playing egg rolls those are
expensive to me i know there was like a large
portion it wasn't like little mini ones that
come on the side of it they were full-blown full
for the most part like i don't really care when
whenever that happens like the big bite thing but
there was one time what happened
like three times that week and i just
i couldn't i could handle it it's it's not a
big thing you know uncrustable oh yeah yeah
and like those are because they're tiny bit right
in the middle where the best part is yeah he's
like can i take the best part of your meal i was
like and i looked i was like what the hell like
the first couple times he's like oh sorry babe
it's not cute and then the third time he's like
why do you keep getting [ __ ] mad over this
and i'm like dude anything love to put it on
us yeah always like like i always see the memes
like when your girlfriend knows to take a bite
and she eats the whole thing like you know it's
[ __ ] you but it's you you stop projecting it
we never had that but um there was a really weird
thing we had in the beginning that it took years
to come to light um when we first started dating i
if i wanted a bite of his food he'd give me a bite
vice versa whatever except for when i wanted
a bite of his burrito once he wouldn't do it
he wouldn't let me have a bite of his burrito
and i was like what the [ __ ] did you just say
just give me a bite and we got actually got into
a little bit of an argument because not about the
burrito but just like why like why won't you let
me have a brand he's like it's gross it's like you
know burrito i don't know it's wet and like you
know drool gets in there i'm like drooling how are
you eating drooling you're asian you're wrong yeah
and like how the [ __ ] would you think i'm gonna
backwash your burrito yeah like what the [ __ ]
and so every time like because i forgot a couple
times about the burrito thing and so i would ask
him for a bite and he's like not with burritos and
he was just like took this stand against having
a bite of his burrito and then like speed forward
to like five six years go by we're well into
our marriage he's eating a burrito and um and
i'm like i know you don't want me to have a bite
of that but i really want to try it but can i cut
it or like you know like have a bite he's like
dude you could have a [ __ ] bite oh he's like
i don't know what my problem was i had a weird
thing one time like where i just thought i had to
take a stand in the beginning of our relationship
because my ex and like i just had a lot of like
weird boundary issues and and then after i did
it the first time i felt like i had to keep up
because it was like the burrito and not like not
the burrito it was like about the burrito and so
i just kept go it going and i'm so sorry about
that like i don't have a thing about burritos
that is a long standing day for years they
went like for like the first two years of our
relationship i was like he's really [ __ ] weird
about burritos we had a fight about it like a few
times i can't have a bite and like yeah because
i would forget because he shared all of his other
food but just a [ __ ] burrito wouldn't let me
have a bite and he's like made up this whole
he was getting upset that i would backwash
his blood but then he needed to stand by it
yeah and then he's like [ __ ] i need to
i need to commit i gotta get out of here
i don't think i've ever said no to anyone like
friend significant other or family that's asked
for some of my food i just don't know how to say
no yeah it's like like how would you say no it
won't be my justification for that right no no i
want it i've never said no i don't think i would
ever say no now but i was kind of a drum freak
when i was a kid and um especially with like ice
cream like you know when like like yeah kind
of lick your ice cream cone or your lollipop
yeah like okay yeah that feels singular yeah and
i wouldn't eat i wouldn't eat it if my mom licked
my ice cream i'm like that's an unspoken rule
that i assume everyone knows though you don't
ask to lick someone's ice cream right thank you
no you don't i wouldn't be sucking on a lollipop
and be like you want something yeah exactly my
aunt thought it was really funny if i was eating
a popsicle to come along and bite the tip of it
and i was like yeah i can't eat it now i would
jokingly like if i was dating someone that i would
jokingly just like eat my lollipop and i'd be like
see that's funny that it's funny though yeah but
like i don't i think it's an unspoken rule like
you don't ask someone for that you know yeah you
wanna know the grossest thing though so i had this
thing like with the saliva thing i couldn't handle
it and then in seventh grade um we go on eighth
grade we go on this like class trip to washington
dc is like for like spring break and like you're
learning about like our nation's history blah
blah blah and it was only like you know a few
like a like a classroom full of kids our age
that got to go and um my crush was there and
he had no idea that i liked him like we weren't
in any classes together he was in the other class
and like we got to like you know be in hotel rooms
and like we're on the whole trip together i kept
trying to sit next to him and we got went to this
candy shop where you get like rock candy rocky
and so the swizzle sticks and like so i was like
i was you know eating it and then he's like can
i have some it's a swizzle stick you know it's
all saliva yeah oh [ __ ] crush so it was like no
no and he like like i gave it back and
i was like and like it's like we kissed
but i was like that was the first
and only time i even shared a lot
ever shared a lollipop or an ice
cream or anything and i was like
this is gross but also it's you oh but the
things we do for love yeah it's very particular
because it gets all in the crevices yeah
it's like it's like you're slurping up
you know drool in general like we talked about
like oral sex like i don't like drool like just
at all that's the only time i love joel like
saliva a lot of people do and it's very normal
but for some reason i just can't handle it like i
picture it no going down my ass crack and i just
i just can't handle the viscosity of it yeah yeah
no and and steve's very good at not backwashing
yeah so i don't know how he eats a burrito but
if it's anything like he eats up my pajamas
you shouldn't watch that burrito worry about it
yeah i remember like sharing drinks wise like i
remember when i was little my uncle would share
my drink with me and then when he pulls like the
straw drink out there's like a trail of jewels
yeah i'm just like yeah you can hold on to that
you can keep that it's yours now that's yours i
don't want to see the drool or the spit you know
like if i don't see it yeah it's probably
fine it's not there yeah yeah but they say
that um the last sip of any beverage is 50
saliva sorry like ever since i learned that
and that might not be true i learned this when i
was a kid and it stuck with me forever it might
not be true at all but i have never been able to
drink the last sip of a drink children do backlash
i think that's a good spot to end this episode
because now i don't ever want to take the last sip
of anything that i shared with anyone oh my god uh
okay guys thanks for watching this episode on uh
um but please follow jessly zama we're gonna have
all her socials down below is there anything you
want to promote anything you want to say uh i
think we talked a lot about finding the one and
i think everything we said here is uh communicate
communicate boundaries set boundaries systems for
committing yourself to forever and then you'll
be okay mm-hmm you're gonna be okay okay and uh
don't cheer burritos okay make sure you guys
uh like give us five stars thumbs up comment
down below about how you feel about [ __ ]
burritos i don't know man we just grossed out
something we're lonely leave us something now
i have in my brain is saliva gina's single she
needs something to read give her a message
this is true all right we love you guys bye
you